si vous deviez choisir de vivre dans un
seul lieu toute votre vie vous
choisiriez la France ou la Belgique
ça mérite un petit coup de bière
Stéphane de grotte bonsoir
je vous appelle toujours Stéphane de
Groodt mais de gros ça veut rien dire
c'est juste pour vous faire chier mais
de gros de gros non vous dites où là de
grandes de grottes appelle-moi Stéphane
alors désolé pour la fouille à l'entrée
du studio mais comme vous venez de
Bruxelles
en tout cas ça fait du bien de voir un
Belge qui veut nous faire rire
alors Stéphane quand vous étiez petit
vous rêviez de devenir pilote de course
auteur acteurs et aujourd'hui vous avez
réalisé Stéphane tous vos rêves
d'enfants il ne vous manque plus que
construire une maison en pain d'épice
je
voudrais alors comme auteur j'ai fait un
tabac avec voyage en Absurdie retour en
Absurdie et aujourd'hui Stéphane vous
revenez avec le livre de la jongle
publié ses plombs en éditeur plan
c'est du lourd
les jeux de mots tout le monde trouve ça
génial quand c'est vous et quand c'est
Ruquier quand c'est moi tout le monde
trouve ça ringard
non mais c'est pas tant des jeux de mots
j'ai l'impression que je joue avec les
mots je sais pas moi on parle toujours
de vraiment de veau sur de pire des
proches moi c'est plutôt un mec comme
Gainsbourg qui m'inspirait pierre
magnifique pierre Repp mais ça c'est
dans la forme mais j'adore mais on
entend plus beaucoup
il y a qu'une bonne façon au fond de
faire le bœuf mitofan le bœuf Mitterrand
le meuf miront le meuf le
d'ailleurs il y a certainement une
erreur dans le mot français auriez-vous
parce que les Italiens disent Mirone
donne en couronne ils ont raison ils ont
raison puisqu'on dispose la bonne on
dispose la bonne viande en couronne
enfin bref cette recette elle est sans
ça essayez-la c'est celle-ci et voilà
chers
un exercice
on se rend pas compte mais c'est très
compliqué de faire ça vous pensez quoi
du premier jeu de mots de tous les temps
celui de Jésus tu es pierre et sur cette
pierre je bâtirai mon Église alors le
pitch vous revisitez 200 expressions
françaises à votre manière alors ce qui
est très drôle je trouve c'est que bien
que belge
vous n'avez pas radicalisé votre humour
se faire péter l'audience alors ce qu'on
va faire maintenant c'est que je vous
demander parce que moi je suis moins bon
que vous de lire vous-même j'écris des
bouquins juste pour pas de voir les lire
et maintenant je dois faire
je rassure les téléspectateurs ce n'est
pas mon livre il y a pas 200 expressions
là
sans crier sans crier gare vous avez de
grandes chances que le chauffeur de taxi
vous emmène à l'aéroport
dormir en Chine fusil si votre femme a
du chien qu'elle vous regarde en chien
de faïence et se couche en chienne fusil
attendez-vous un royal canin
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant des fois je rêve que je
suis milliardaire et que je suis obligé
d'aller vivre en Belgique c'est pas une
punition ah bon
il y a d'autres endroits que la Belgique
plusieurs soleils
c'est sympa la Belgique mais ceci je
peux vous convier à aller faire un petit
tour sur la Grand-Place en Belgique
[Musique]
ça va Stéphane mais ça va super bien bon
j'ai quoi là des frites là moi je mange
des frites
et légumes par jour donc le beige mange
des frites c'est quand même bizarre un
pays dont dans la statue la plus connue
c'est un petit garçon qui fait pipi dans
l'eau
les américains ils ont quand même une
femme comme ça très grande très belle
qui tient une torche qui éclaire le
monde et tout et vous avez un môme qui
pisse dans l'eau quoi
C'est ça la vraie liberté ah eux ils ont
la statue nous on a la stature
le belge n'est pas fier c'est pour ça
qu'il est belle
[Applaudissements]
tu deviens choisir de vivre dans un seul
lieu tout de votre vie vous choisiriez
la France ou la Belgique
ça mérite un petit coup de bière
très bon les bières chaudes
un territoire entre les deux qui
s'appellerait la frangique
à part le Manneken-Pis il y a le truc à
voir en Belgique et la jeune à Cannes
peace
pour faire pipi ah ouais comme le
mannequin-piste et c'est où ça c'est pas
loin de la place
tout de suite
est-ce qu'en Belgique
on peut visiter la maison de Philippe
geluc
si vous êtes pas chien avec lui je pense
qu'il vous fera visiter sa maison est-ce
qu'on peut visiter Adamo mais comme tous
les monuments
j'ai connu le temps au Bruxelles Bruce
Lee ah mais vous me parlez de la
Belgique là mais Bruxelles chante
toujours bouger le danse et on danse la
Belgique
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu